the powerful demon inside the hero it's
an anime Trope As Old As Time Naruto and
the ninet tales AA in Black Clover
Ichigo in Bleach Ino Yasha chainsaw man
the list goes on and on and on and if
you've watched any anime like ever you
will know that the main character always
always has to face his inner demon
overcome it and then in the end grow
stronger you know it's a metaphor and so
it's actually quite refreshing that judu
kaisen took this particular anime Trope
like so many others and completely
flipped it on its head as itadori Yuji
is just crushed over and over again by
the far stronger and far smarter sukuna
however what if Yuji was more like the
rest of shen protagonists and could
actually learn to control sukuna and
make use of his truly insane Powers
because this one change would make the
entire story of judu kaisen completely
different so when normal but very very
strong high school student Yuji tadori
finds himself face to face with a
monstrous curse terrorizing his friends
he makes a split-second decision that
changes his entire life as you'll
remember he eats a special great cursed
object AKA one of the 20 fingers of
sukuna and as Gojo reminds us this isn't
counting toes yet sukuna has four arms
because he's just built different and
normally this should kill him instantly
but Yuji is a super wrong special Shen
protagonist so instead he emerges as a
suitable vessel for sukuna the problem
is Yuji isn't actually able to access
any of sua's insane Powers he can just
take back control of his body and
suppress sakuna inside of him but what
would it be like if instead of just
being able to take back control of his
body Yuji could actually just directly
access sukuna insane powers and well
first off I think sat Gojo would just
end up being a a lot more suspicious of
this whole situation in the regular
story he fought with sakuna for 10
seconds as a test to see if Yuji could
actually take control at will but if
regular Yuji was also as strong as
sakuna without him taking over he'd
probably be a lot more likely to think
sakuna was just acting with his best
Yuji impression to trick them into
thinking that he was actually being
suppressed Yuji would just let slashes
fly giving Gojo about a million cuts
that he'd have to heal with his revers
curse technique and Gojo would probably
end up asking Yuji a series of questions
that only the real Yuji could actually
know for example he probably asked stuff
like what's your birthday what's your
mother's maiden name it's Kaku what's
the name of the street you grew up on
you know and then of course migoi would
yell at his Sensei because of course
neither of them would have any clue
themselves what the answers to those
questions would actually be and the
higher-ups in particular would want Yuji
even more that than they already do just
like they did in the regular story after
all the one thing possibly more
dangerous than a resurrected ancient
curse user is a teenager with unlimited
power however after Gojo was fully
satisfied that it was indeed Yuji in
control he would still vouch for him and
convince the higher-ups after all he is
Gojo and he could simply stop Yuji if he
went Rog since he only had one fingers
worth of power at this point of course
only shortly after yuji's power level
would start growing to two fingers as
Gojo would give him another one that Jay
had been holding on to as a means of
testing his ability as a vessel and as
you know with each finger that sakuna
regains his total power grows however in
the regular story this doesn't at all
affect yuji's base power he still very
much needs to work on developing his own
strength from zero because he's
completely unable to tap into sukuna
well of power in our scenario though all
of that finger power may as well be
yuji's because he can now use it without
actually having to give up control of
sukuna at all and so now let's Flash
forward to yuji's next big moment for a
lot of fans the point where they
realized that jutu kaisen was not their
standard series was when the main
character nearly literally died in just
the sixth episode however in this
timeline with Yugi actually getting
access to sua's powers without him
totally losing control things would go
very differently when the special great
cursed Spirit showed up spawning from
the cursed womb in case you don't
remember this cursed womb then became a
special great spirit called a finger
Bearer specifically because it had
consumed one of sakuna fingers and so
now instead of Yuji meoi and no's only
options being to run or die this time
itadori would have the power to actually
fight now in the actual show sukuna made
really short work of this powerful
cursed Spirit but in exchange Yuji lost
control of his body and sakuna was able
to take him hostage AKA ripping out his
actual heart and threatening to kill him
only offering to use his reverse curse
technique to heal him if he'll actually
make a binding vow and this vow unknown
to Yuji since he literally had to forget
about it due to the conditions of that
bargain would have terrible terrible
consequences down the line however if
Yuji could use sukuna strength without
the downsides he'd eliminate the cursed
Spirits pretty much with no problem
sakuna showed the cursed wom his domain
expansion but since Yuji wouldn't even
know what that was at this point he
probably just put the curs spirit
Through The Slap Chop and cut it into a
million cursed pieces kind of treatments
and then the gang of the three would all
be free to grab a bowl of ramen
afterwards but of course that's not the
only thing that Yuji gets to CH down on
because he'd also be free to chump on
yet another sukuna finger that was
housed inside the cursed womb once again
this would bring Yuji to a power level
of exactly three fingers at this point
and as you remember it's around the same
time that Joo would actually try to kill
Gojo however this time Yuji wouldn't be
in secret training since well he didn't
fake die I'm going to say that Gojo
would probably still have him do his
Netflix binge watch training program
thing to try and have him get a hang of
cursed energy and as yuji's finger
number increases more and more the risk
of sukuna gaining control would be
higher and higher so having him complete
his cursed energy training would be
especially important here after all even
if sakuna didn't take control somebody
without experience trying to use his
powers might very much cause Untold
destruction just by accident so anyways
Mr volcano head here would want to have
a serious word with go Jo foolishly
thinking that he was even remotely a
match for him and by the way I really
wish that his name was actually just Mr
volcano hat that way I wouldn't just
have to keep getting Joo and Gojo mixed
up in my script all the time so uh
thanks gig for that I guess and just
like in the main series Gojo would use
this opportunity to teach Yuji about the
wonderful world of domain expansions
this time though after seeing Gojo's
unlimited void in action Yugi would just
say oh oh let me try that and whip out a
malevolent Shrine or as a crunchy roll
likes to call it I guess a malevolent
kitchen however Joo isn't getting cooked
just yet we'll save that for Shibuya
because outclassed by not just one but
two JSU Sorcerers at this point Joo
would once again flee the scene with the
help of his most flowy friends and
decide that maybe just maybe he does
need kaku's help with Gojo after all and
so onto jume in the real timeline of Jud
kaisen Yuji befriends a high school
student called jume unfortunately though
this guy jume had also made another
friend recently Maho the human curse
just to be clear here that's not like a
human SL curse combo like sakuna Mao is
a curse born from Humanity's fear of
itself making him one of the scariest
curses altogether now due to Jump's
parents being divorced and his constant
bullying at school he has adopted an
extremely negative view of humanity and
Mao takes advantage of this but Yuji
genuinely tries to become jum's friends
however as you remember this short Arc
accumulates in a huge battle at jum's
high school when MTO uses his Idol
Transfiguration to turn jumpe into a
monster who he can use against Yuji and
at least according to Mao himself there
is no way to bring jume back to life
Yuji beg sakuna for help because he does
know that sakuna can mul heal wounds
after all he just replaced yuji's entire
heart with reversed cursed technique
however in the real series sukuna and
MTO just laugh and mock Yuji in one of
the most me mble panels from the whole
series I mean gig akutami really knows
how to draw a really demented smile I
guess however if Yuji could actually
control sua's powers that would include
his reverse curse technique and using
that power he could probably reverse
mto's ability MTO states that it's
impossible to do so but for all we know
MTO just says that to harm Yuji even
more and maybe with the power of someone
like sakuna it might be possible after
all and at this point I think it would
be nice if you kaisen took a q from One
Piece because Mao would make an
excellent shocked enl face as jume was
being deep platypus I guess in fact he'd
be so in shock that he'd barely see it
coming when Yuji pulled out the death by
1,000 Cuts now Mao can change the shape
of souls but his soul would be in about
a billion trillion pieces after Yuji was
done with him here because in AR Yuji
would be able to fight against him with
the full strength of sukuna AKA Mao is
getting cooked in the malevolent kitchen
after all Yuji is no match for Mao at
this point in the story but zuna's
Powers outclass him by Miles and as you
can imagine Mao being super dead at this
point is going to really come into play
a lot later you know because off Shibuya
but for now jume and Yuji would
celebrate jume realizing the errors of
his ways after Mao took advantage of him
and the two teenagers would go you know
catch a movie where absolutely no heads
exploded up next we get a family reunion
where itadori gets to meet his siblings
enter the cursed womb death paintings
now these guys are kind of like the
cursed wombs from earlier only way worse
they were created by kenju the ultimate
villain of Jutsu kaisen who was
inhabiting the body of niosi camo who
gained the title of the most evil
sorcerer in history and in order to
create the death paintings he mixed the
blood of Cur spirits and humans to
create creatures who were a kind of
hybrid form of both and since Kaku is
also yuji's mother long story this does
make ISO kisu and choso here technically
his brothers Step Brothers half Brothers
curs brothers and once again the team of
meomi kugisaki and Yuji will destroy
these guys here and Yuji will slurp up
yet another delicious finger and at this
point it's of course the moment that
you've all been waiting for Happy
Halloween because in Jutsu kaisen time
it is October 31st the night of the
Shibuya incident and as you might
suspect this is where the differences in
our scenario really start coming along
heavily because Yuji has already
destroyed kaku's plans here MTO was
essential for helping keep Gojo busy and
distracted so that he could trick him
into getting caught by the prison realm
Mao also kills fan favorites nanin and
probably NOA and I mean come on gig
akutami would it kill you to just let us
know what actually happened to our
favorite Hammer girl already anyways in
this scenario the disaster curses are
espe espcially motivated to get rid of
Gojo and Yuji because they need Gojo
clear so they can fulfill their goal of
taking out humanity and letting curses
rule the world the group would probably
still somehow manage to successfully
capture Gojo but less thanks to the
disaster curses like in the actual story
and much more thanks to the human
disaster kinjaku or pseudo ghetto as
Gojo sees him and so again most likely
the world's strongest sorcerer would be
caught in the prison realm leaving the
rest of the fighters to deal with the
three special great curses and their
allies Choo would still fight Yuji and
slow him down from being able to set
Gojo free before the prison realm was
sealed allowing Gojo to actually still
be captured once again choso would use
his blood manipulation to fire off
rounds at Yuji but he dodged them all
with ease and just before Yuji uses his
sukuna powers to just absolutely chop up
choso to Pieces they would realize that
they are actually Brothers now Yuji
would be very confused but glad to
accept another Ally on their side as the
two go down to face the remaining
disaster curses now during this Arc
mimiko and nanako would still feed Yuji
a finger these two girls were followers
of suguru gheto prior to his death and
therefore wanted to offer a finger as an
offering to sukuna so that they could
actually ask him to kill kinjaku for
them since he had taken over their old
Master's body it does get very confusing
I know now in the actual story sukuna
ends up killing them perceiving them
giving him an order as an unforgivable
offense however Yuji will be more than
happy to use the finger booze to go
after Kaku especially since kenju just
imprisoned his own master and so the
ever polite Yuji would just bow deeply
after getting the gift of another finger
and then go running off after kinjaku on
the other hand Joo would absolutely not
give Yuji the 10 fingers that he has
been hoarding since the king of curses
sukuna was essentially being held
hostage By Yuji in this alternate
timeline he would want those fingers as
far away from Yuji as he could possibly
get them and so instead in our timeline
it would essentially come down to an
allout battle between the disaster
curses Kaku and yuji's FiveFinger Death
Punch however Yuji would have the
backing of the other judu sorceress of
course Hanami the nature curse was
already exercised by Gojo before he was
even trapped in the prison realm dog on
the water-based curse would still be a
problem but just like he does in the
regular series The recently resurrected
toi fushiguro would still be there to
help beat the curse up into a pulp and
so Joo would actually end up being the
biggest problem of the three now now 15
finger sukuna actually made pretty short
work of him but this time Yugi would
only have five fingers worth of strength
here and therefore I think he wouldn't
be able to just absolutely Flex on Mr
volcano hat here with his own fire-based
attack instead Yuji would actually use
his regular strategy of dicing and
slicing and punching I guess to turn
joogo into minced meat and so at this
point all that's really left is Kaku but
after seeing everything that had just
gone down well let's just say that Kaku
is probably smart enough to read the
room and know when to dip getting up
close and personal with the combat isn't
really kaku's usual style this dude can
absolutely fight if he needs to but he's
not trying to take on all of judu high
plus a sukuna strengthened Yuji at the
same time after all he is quite cunning
and manipulative he likes to make plans
and have others enact them for him but
he has a real problem because since he's
now lost MTO his biggest strategy for
enacting the culling game by stealing
his ability was already gone as well and
therefore having succeeded in his goal
of sealing Gojo he would Retreat to
gather new allies and fight another day
now sadly that would mean that he
wouldn't get to reunite with his beloved
Son Yuji just yet but it would only be a
matter of time before he would get
things to go his way once again of
course if Yuji did have control of
sukuna powers the show wouldn't be
nearly as interesting unless they gave
Yuji an enemy who was truly on his level
because think about it if Suk kuna's
power were on the side of good what
character in the world could possibly
rival him well I mean I guess there is
Satur Gojo now thankfully he is on the
good side as well but if his backstory
had gone just a little bit differently
could his insane power have gotten to
his head and made him go against judu
Society what would it actually have
looked like if Gojo had turned evil well
to find the answer to that question you
can watch that video right here thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next
one